[Music]
even with all this success that we've
had he still feels like he's in survival
mode you know pressure from the business
kind of just sucks the fun out of our
life is causing me to get defensive
and it's affecting how we enjoy each
other
what's up this is john with the dr john
dalone show
the best marriage and parenting and
mental health podcast ever so glad that
you're with us if you want to be a
caller on the show if you want to
pull up a seat and we can figure it out
whatever's going on in your life whether
it's school issues or kid issues or
spouse or
dating issues or mental health
whatever's going on give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
a-s-k ask all right let's go to hamilton
new jersey what's up lynn how are we
doing
hi dr john it's such an honor to speak
to you thanks so much for taking the
call it's an honor for me i i'm grateful
that you called what's up
so
um me and my husband have been married
for 23 years
and we run a home-based business where
we work together on the daily
it's been super successful
my husband's an awesome entrepreneur he
does an amazing job
you know
responding to challenges adapting to
growth it's it's been
a huge success we have substantial
savings
um we live debt free we have a paid off
home
my challenges is even with all this
success that we've had he still feels
like he's in survival mode
if our business isn't growing
and we're working working working
and i feel like we're not on the same
page anymore is in regard to
work life
balance
okay
you know pressure from the business
kind of just sucks the fun out of our
life is causing me to get defensive
and it's affecting how we enjoy each
other
and just live our daily life gotcha
gotcha um
so what do you want to do
well um
i love the business i love that we have
flexibility i love um
you know the day-to-day work
i personally would like to scale back
travel a little bit more but um again he
feels like he's in this
survival mode
which to me is not the case right
uh it's pretty common and you you know
this i mean you live it um
that
people can turn their vocation their
business their job into
who they are
and that sentiment you know if you're
not growing you're dying
right whatever that is
yeah um that that can become a personal
identity
if i'm not making more money than i made
last quarter that i i me i am failing
and if i'm failing i have nothing
and so i've got to do whatever i can do
to make sure this this proxy this thing
that i have outsourced my identity to
this business
and by the way business has a dollar
amount right it's got a score card and
so i i just get a real time
you can't find out if you did a good job
with your kids right until a teacher
tells you or until they marry well or
whatever
your business tells you every day if
you're failing or if you're winning
right all that to say is this um i don't
think this is a business question at all
i think this is a life question
and i
just listen to you talk i i think you
like your life that this business
affords you more than the business is
that fair
very 100 spot on okay
um
and my guess is your husband very
similar he may not love the business as
much as the business gives him or has
propped him up for a long long time
yeah and um at some point
that it'll kill you
right or you'll die of natural causes i
think here's the ultimate question
uh who do we want to become now
and
that usually just take has couples
sitting down saying okay we are
50 we are 65 what are what have we done
all of this for if not to enjoy it and
not to go live our lives
and so the question is who are we gonna
be
i would love to see you
this is just me throwing a grenade in
your home
um for fun and also i'm being kind of
serious i would love to see you turn in
like a six weeks notice
[Music]
i'm resigning okay
i'm not going to work here anymore
because i want to go enjoy my life and i
would love for you to come with me
and i would love for you to go on dates
with me and go hiking and whatever
things y'all want to do go salsa dance
or whatever the thing is uh
i would love for you to do that with me
and you can choose to
value
grinding and killing and crushing it
more than you value doing those things
with me but i'm gonna go do them
so when i just said that
your voice tone changed
why
i agree with you it it
i thought it would scare me when you
first were saying it but i i i'm kind of
into it i'm kind of digging it just
resign
you work for yourself you can quit
yeah and i'm saying that was smile on my
face
is that does that sound freeing
it sounds amazing
okay here's here's the big question most
of the times couples get into
discussions that turn into debates that
turn into fights
and it's about money
our business
it's about um
well who's gonna that kind of stuff
this isn't that conversation
this conversation is honey we have
enough
i want a different kind of life now
or i want a life that looks like x y or
z
and then what kind of work or business
can we put into that life that supports
it but that that the world doesn't
revolve around that anymore and for
those listening who are younger there
are seasons when you're 20 and you're 30
when your life has to revolve around
you've you've got to get yourself in a
position to be st for stability right
that's every job throughout all of
history
and now there's a big thing for 20 year
olds that are quitting
and like i'm just gonna
um
i don't know i'm just gonna get a
minimum wage job cause i'm gonna live
and love my life and that just means i'm
gonna play video games or i'm gonna go
hiking or whatever and i think that's a
terrible mistake
but you are the opposite of that y'all
put all the work and time in
and here you are right how old are you
uh he just turned 50 i'm 52. so we've
put years
of sacrifice in
and you're 10 years ahead of the curve
if not 20 years right
i'd like to think so yeah okay could you
could you hire somebody to run this
business that would provide you y'all
with some money and some purpose and
he's still a part of it but also some
flexibility or is it really built
built around him and you it
it's
i think it's built around him because we
have
made it built around him
you're so smart i love it i love it you
know if that makes sense
that's a really nice way to say i'm
married to somebody with a sizable ego
and
it's worked for us so far
[Laughter]
and that's another thing we we are
challenged with too is
sometimes you know things aren't done
perfectly or aren't done exactly the way
so i think that would be
a challenge in
it's it's not being done the way he
would do it right so i'll just do it
myself oh and it's got my name on it so
i'm the buck stops with me all those
noble ideas that have become quotes over
time
become a way of living and then there's
a spouse and there's a kids and then
there's a person inside of him that's
going
yeah what about life though right yep so
it's both hand
yeah it's both in so here's something my
wife did for me i think i've mentioned
on the show um a little bit um so i've
worked in non-profits my whole career
i've been in education forever working
at universities and in public schools
and so coming to this job was the
it was like somebody opened the
floodgates for me
where
i was on call for for for 365 24 7 for
almost 20 years and if i went to the
hospital four nights a week to be with
students and i got up at 2 a.m to deal
with drunk students three nights a week
my paycheck stayed the same
and if i
built a new residence hall or recruited
a thousand new students my paycheck
stayed the same this is the first time
it's like man
you write another book then you get more
money and if you get on the road and go
speak at more places and go do more
consulting you make more right so
it has
i feel like i have had some tethers just
clipped and i'm running as fast as i can
and it was this past christmas break
that my wife sat down and said john we
have enough
you i i
i need you
and that was really hard for me to hear
and she was right and she said your kids
need you
and from this point forward anytime you
think you're going to go quote unquote
make some more money for us
i need you to hear
me say that's not true it's a lie that
you're telling yourself
and it too that like cut me i was like
you know what i mean uh yeah the same as
she said we don't need any more deep
freezers like we're good all right so
same thing right and so or we don't need
more guitars or guns or anything like
that so there was a wisdom there though
that i had to look in the mirror and say
i'm running and running and running and
i'm telling myself it's for these other
people but it's for me
yeah it's for me and it's fine that it's
for me that's good but it's coming at a
cost of exactly that was hard
but i would love to see you put in your
six week notice and see what i'll see
what happens how do you think how do you
think he'll respond to that
i'm just curious
i i think it would be
a wake-up call okay
and um you know i'm sure it would lead
us to the bigger discussion that needs
to happen but i i kind of like the shock
factor of it
don't get me in trouble okay here's if
i'm you here's how i would do this and
again every marriage is different i
would set up a nice dinner we'd go
somewhere we'd not wait until there's
like already uh we're already fighting
about something else and it would be
something planned i have an announcement
to make i would also
do i know you've fantasized about this
but be concrete about it what would you
do instead
because you can't do nothing right you
got to have a purpose you've got to have
are we going to go visit people are we
going to get an rv are we going to work
from
like what are we going to do just not
nothing right yeah yep um
okay let me know how that goes and uh if
you want to call about uh
please don't blow things up actually you
know what it's your life you can do it
every week do whatever you want to
i love it and by the way
it this is
i feel like i need to say this on behalf
of people like me and your husband
he's doing this because he loves you a
lot
right
a hundred percent understood and i
i don't want to feel
or
come across as ungrateful
because
you know we are where we are because of
it
but
something's got to give that's right i
think there's a way to do it not where
you're ungrateful where you are super
grateful yes like you've given us 30
years of your life
yeah and now we want you to take your
life back
yep i love it and i quit i'd be so good
oh man oh man you're awesome lynn thank
you so much for that call um yeah let me
know how that one goes i can't wait to
hear it we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
deloney
all right we are back let's go to spinx
in brewton alabama spanx what's up dude
how are you dr john rock and rolling man
how about yourself
i'm well thank you
you bet so what's up man
okay so let me give you a brief summary
of kind of how we got here and then i'll
ask my question if that's okay you got
it
so i am a broadcast meteorologist and
you sound like a meteorologist you sound
like one thanks
thank you
so i wanted to do weather and be a
meteorologist pretty much my whole life
i was really fascinated with whether as
a kid and really fortunate to have a
grandmother who
you know created experiences and bought
me things and encouraged me from a very
young age to kind of go down that path
if i chose to sure so graduated college
went to college at the
university of alabama in tuscaloosa you
had to get that in there didn't you you
just had to get that in there
oh that's right that's right all right
i'll give you that one
i actually grew up an auburn fan if that
makes you feel better
no both of them are they're both
terrible but whatever you got it in
there so there you go
yeah at least you're not an ag all right
go for it
there you go
so went to college and then worked
briefly in television in the birmingham
alabama television market and then i
actually moved back to my hometown to be
a full-time youth minister which kind of
opened my eyes to a totally different
world that i had never really you know
been in so i realized about a year into
that job that i wanted to get back into
broadcast weather so i started a company
to keep my feet wet and
that ended up turning into a part-time
job and subsequently a full-time job and
thankfully the company has done really
well and that's due in part to
you know the principle that you all
teach you and dave ramsey on a daily
basis those are kind of ingrained as a
company and
really thankful to have kind of been a
ramsey person my whole life um but over
the last few years
i've really had more and more people
message me about having severe weather
anxiety
and specifically tornado anxiety
not only you know the messages
but also sometimes when i'm in public
people will see me and want to talk
about their severe weather experiences
and their you know severe weather
anxiety so my question for you is this
what are some effective ways
that i can help to alleviate this severe
weather anxiety and i guess kind of
elaborating on that
what would you say to me
and to people in my industry as a mental
health professional as far as you know
do you have any suggestions on how we
can be more effective communicators
during you know crises like tornadoes
yes dude i love this question
i love it for a few reasons one um
i grew up in houston the gulf and so
i've i've been sheltering in place and
getting in bathtubs with mattresses
since i was a little bit of a kid right
so i've got uh my own
ingrained uh weather anxiety and i i've
had to work through it over the past
five to six or seven years and it's been
i love this question from for a personal
reason
can i be super blunt and honest with you
or you need to like talk peripherally
no be super blunt
okay i'm going to speak to you as i'm
clowning on you but um it's actually for
the entire ecosystem is that cool
yes absolutely i think i know where this
is going you're such a great person i
appreciate you taking one for the team
right okay
so i think let's answer this from kind
of the top of the funnel anxiety
to make it really easy um can distill
down into three buckets right
um
am i scared does your body detecting
that something scary is happening
whether you're an abusive relationship
you're not safe
uh it remembers a time when you drove on
this road and you were making this left
turn when you got in a bad car accident
so it's gonna start it put a pin in that
right so there's safety then there is
disconnection like i don't i'm out of
step with my community i don't have any
relationships my body has found me alone
it's gonna sound the alarms or the third
one is autonomy right i am not in
control of tomorrow i'm not in control
of my next step
and when we get in weather situations
that's one of those few moments
when you are completely and totally out
of control
you're scared to death and often we find
ourselves isolating alone so feeling
anxious about weather
is right and it's good and it's not
something that we're not broken when we
when we get nervous about it what
happens though is the ecosystem that
we've created for ourselves when it
comes to how media communicates weather
i think has shifted from i'm giving you
good information to i need to get clicks
and sell ads
and this
this is
this is a critique of the
internet media of course but it's bled
over into
public right
so now i when it's raining outside
um
i can turn on the news is to check it
out and it will be a big bright bold red
breaking news breaking weather update
right you see what i'm saying everything
is designed to get me to focus in on
there and to sound the alarms that i'm
not safe right
sure and
there's the broader conversation that
tells us that because of climate change
we're going to have more tornadoes more
hurricanes are going to be more
aggressive we're going to hail storms
the crops are going to all fail right
what's the latest one is
that the government is and rich people
are drumming up a food shortage like
we're being fed this all the time that
we're gonna die we're gonna die we're
gonna die and that weather and climate
are the reason
and so that that's coming from the
inside out right
and
storms are escalating and the weather's
bananas and what used to be right right
so it is actually happening too and so
it's this both and
um so i think it's
your question is incredibly important
because you sit at as the person people
go to when they're anxious or when
they're scared and they've got all this
baggage that they're bringing with them
and they look at you and say help
right and so then what do we do
and i think from my perspective too i'm
kind of in a unique position because
like i said i started a company
essentially
um being you know the tv weather caster
but i own you know the company from from
the top down right and so i think too a
lot of folks don't realize or it seems
to me that a lot of folks don't realize
that these larger media conglomerates
that own
these local television stations you're
right are pushing the narrative you know
from the top down and sometimes that
you know can lead to um
you know local meteorologists pushing
things in a way that may not be as
helpful not to say that they're not
doing good work i think they are of
course
but i think that a lot of folks don't
realize that you know a lot of this is
um you know being pushed from the top
sometimes right and
that when they tell you hey things just
turned you're good
that message isn't always communicated
because the goal is to keep you on right
because i want you to keep watching the
watching the station so
sure whenever i'm sitting down with
somebody who's struggling with anxiety
of any kind
a couple of things guide my path there
okay number one is presence i'm gonna
show up
and i think a a
someone who's doing weather is uniquely
positioned especially someone who's not
market hopping and you know how that
whole riga maru goes i'm gonna do two
years on this one and when you're here
and all that
somebody who creates a stable presence
i'll be here right
and you can trust me and you can also
trust that i'm gonna probably oversell
it this way or undersell it this way we
had a guy in one of my communities i
lived in they'd call him run for the
hill
ron roberts or whatever his name was but
but but but also everybody went to him
every single time
and
like it's kind of like delony comes in
and i'm like i saw the best movie ever
they know it wasn't the best movie ever
but they know it's pretty good but they
know me right there's a presence
and so presence is number one a big one
that i follow is facts are your friends
when somebody's stressed out when
somebody is fried
what they need is
very limited true data
when a mother
opens the door and there's an officer
standing there in full uniform and i'm
standing there
she instantly knows something's happened
if i start with well it was raining
really hard and there were cars right
that's not how you do that
you open the door and say ma'am there
was a car accident and your son was in
the car and he has died
facts are your friends and there's a
period there and i'm going to be i'm
going to say it directly i'm going to
say it forward right and then after we
pick her up and take her inside over the
next couple of hours there will be
discussions and back and forth and one
of the things that i was trying to do
that i'm pretty good at is
those conversations go up and down and
up and down and up and down so there's
going to be some strange moments of deep
guttural laughter sometimes and there's
going to be some deep moments of fear
and scared and what do we do and here's
a here's who you call next
so i used that example to tell you
the best group i've ever seen and i grew
up in texas you know how volatile the
weather is in texas
the the the best i've ever seen is this
crew here in nashville the the nashville
severe weather it's a couple of guys who
have a twitter account and i don't even
have twitter but i follow them and
here's why it's great
they say things like hey it's past go to
bed
get off the computer
they'll skip an all clear in other words
yeah it's an all clear but it's an all
clear like i would get from a buddy
not an all clear from an ai
um
they give funny memes
in between their reports
and also they're very um direct when
they say
go get under something now
if you're in this area
and they use that very sparingly and so
what i've come in my four years i've
been in nashville five years i've been
in tennessee
i've come to trust they're funny they're
gonna have moments of levity
if they say jump you better jump because
they're not messing around they're not
playing with you
and they tell me go to bed their goal
isn't to keep me on there as long as
possible their goal is to give me
accurate information
does that make sense
it does make sense yeah so those three
things i think in someone in your like
as a public figure is i'm gonna show up
every time i'm gonna i'm gonna be a
presence for you and i'm gonna give you
true data true information and if it's
no big deal i'm gonna say this is no big
deal go back to bed if it's a huge deal
i'm gonna tell you and three i'm gonna
intersperse humor and connection
wherever i can right whether that's
funny memes whether that's the dad joke
of the day or whether that's whatever
that is here's a recipe for staying up
late since you're going to be up late
tonight because they're going to be
tornadoes all over your area those kind
of things does that make sense
it does make sense absolutely
um i think some leadership in the area
of here's what i'm here's what i'm i'm
nervous about i'm saying i'm actually
scared about it
i'm scared that with escalating weather
and this isn't a political statement and
i still can't beli i can't figure out
for the life of me how weather has
gotten politicized it's bananas to me
right but as it has
become increasingly more volatile and
increasingly more wild right and the
temperature swings in the ring all that
the more noise there is
the more people just disregard it
and the more dangerous it becomes for
everybody and so i would love to see
someone like you sphinx who
says i'm going to be a part of this new
generation
of meteorologists and we're going to
start a conversation
that says hey how do we connect with our
communities again and not try to get
them to buy metamucil ads like whatever
the thing that's going to come up how
can we give them some information that's
going to help them sleep and help them
stay safe
instead of let's get them wound up right
and i know i know that's so easier said
than done because
of the conglomerates you're talking
about but
well and this might be a topic for
another day but what would you say like
one of the things that i encounter
pretty frequently you know
we see on social media
people who have no training in
meteorology you know even sometimes
teenagers that get on facebook and you
know post these wild single image model
runs and kind of pass them off as a
forecast but then they go viral because
um you know it's the shock factor right
and well what do you say like
to folks who kind of are in tune to that
sort of thing um but but you know
perhaps should be more intuned like a
local person who is trained
um two things one you're exactly right
our brains are designed to scan the
environment for the worst possible
outcome because that's how it stays
alive
and
5 000 years ago if or 50 million years
ago whatever if a twig snapped in the
forest it's better that i assume that's
a bear even though it's probably not
because if i'm wrong i'm dead and if i'm
right i just jumped really high nothing
happened right
now you take that same brain wiring and
fast forward and now some 17 year old
with with a with a computer model and a
twitter account can
keep an entire neighborhood awake right
and screw up their weather patterns and
their traffic patterns and their
shopping all that stuff so um i think
that we have to have a generation that
pops up real fast yourself included i'm
thinking of the lane norton's of the
word world the
sal the stefano and the mind pump guys
with fitness um i'm thinking of huberman
when it comes to some of the mental
health stuff and science
this show your show
that will call that out directly
do not get weather advice from a
knuckleheaded facebook account right i'm
just gonna call it what it is and say
somebody is
running their mouth they don't know what
they're talking about um here is actual
data here's actual science and if you
build that trust over time
uh and you don't become an alarm sounder
all the time unless you really need to
sound alarm then people begin to trust
you but there's going to take a group of
people who actually know what they're
talking about to come out of our
laboratories and come off out of our
um
our circles i just like to hang out with
mental health folks that's what i love
to do and i like to hang out with
doctors and lawyers i've got to leave
those circles and start communicating
some of this truth in other ways right
so i think i think you've got to call
that out directly and if somebody if if
a group of people tweet you five or six
or seven of the same photo call it out
say hey i keep getting this photo this
is nonsense hey uh frank at
frank's garage 87
like stop posting stuff you're going to
get people hurt this is nonsense and
it's great
right and i think calling it out
gotcha that's a great one good to know i
think i think it's clear to say that
maybe a little um is certainly easier
said than done especially when you know
the oh everything i just oh dude
everything i just said is easier said
than done yes no question oh sure
totally not saying it's not worth it i
think it is but uh
definitely easier said than done yeah i
no i i think there's got to be some sort
of collective movement to center things
back
um not politically again i don't want to
get your mean cards and letters
everybody but center it back
things are getting crazy when it comes
to weather things are getting extreme
and things are speeding up and i need to
know when it's a big deal for me or not
i need to know when there's a pattern
that's happening over right so i need to
know some of this true data but i also
need it in a not sensationalized time
because it's just a big game of boy
cried wolf
and now people are just starting to
check out right they're just saying i'm
completely out of this conversation
so whether you're a parent whether
you're a
therapist whether you're a psychologist
whether you're a medical doctor whether
you are a meteorologist like sphinx in
his communities whatever you do
the more you bang on drums and cry wolf
the education system's falling apart
we're all gonna it's not it's not
is it a mess right now absolutely
absolutely
um i just was in a meeting this morning
i just i'm i'm taking this on a left
turn but i'm but i'll come back i was
just in a meeting this morning my comp
the company that i worked for um there's
about 1100 employees adopted a single
school this year
and they gave every employee a week off
to go
support this school
there's a group of us a big group of us
that are going to get certified as
substitute teachers
who are going to get certified as aids
who are going to
groups have already come in and cut out
things for teachers make copies do
coffee make breakfast
take this school over and support and
love them because education is not
broken teachers teaching kids isn't
broken
it's teachers having to be
roofers and pavement
employees they have to and craftsmen
and social workers and therapists and
deal with their own homes all for barely
minimum wage and if you do the hour
sometimes it's not even minimum wage
so it's time for people like companies
and like local communities and local
churches to step up and start taking
care of some of these schools right so
that's a group of people in a community
stepping up and saying we have a problem
here let's be a part of the solution
let's just don't throw grenades on
facebook same with same with the weather
same with any number of challenges we
have in our communities let's get a
group of people to step up and start
being a part of that and sphinx shout
out to you and your company for leading
that charge
if you are anxious about whether
finding a
organization find a voice that you trust
whether it's on the internet like the
one i found whether it's a particular um
uh anchor if you will i keep thinking of
anchorman ron burgundy
find somebody who will give you good
information and then turn it off we'll
be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back
check them out at churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back um
during the break uh i went ahead and
sent um spanx
10 copies of redefining anxiety that
looks like 10 bucks and you can get it
at johndaloni.com and it's just a short
primer it's about 60 70 80 pages it's
it's i should probably know that right
um but it's a short book that just walks
through here's what anxiety is here's
what it's not and here's what you can do
to get your life back
um and so i'm gonna send him 10 copies
of that and if you know somebody's
struggling with anxiety grab one pick
one up at the store and it um or on the
internets at john delany.com all right
let's go to christina in omaha nebraska
what's up christina
hey how's it going i'm good how are you
i'm doing great fantastic what's up
all right i have a question i'd like to
get your perspective on
um i have a wonderful all right
i have a wonderful sister who has down
syndrome and she is not getting the care
that she needs
and my question is
how do i confront my mother about these
issues when she believes she isn't doing
the best for her daughter
she believes she is doing the best or
does not believe she's doing the best
she does believe she's doing the best
okay
um walk me through what care is missing
what's going on
oh um the biggest
thing is that
she is having trouble with
um mental health she's
i've heard her describe
that she has hallucinations that
um
that trouble her on like a daily basis
as well as
um
pretty vivid nightmares
okay she also has
she's been going into extreme isolation
where she won't
try and make friends
she also doesn't get very many
opportunities to make friends
um is she in school
she is not she has not had formal
education since she was in kindergarten
my mother um
is a homeschooler but she
doesn't
um
give like
structured homeschool it's more like
a freeform education
not yeah okay you're you're and you know
this i'm just saying it's out loud your
sister has some
very
serious needs
that can be met
have to be met legally right um but can
be met with great care and love and
professionalism in a local school
yeah and she needs those desperately
um
the things you just told me
hallucinations nightmare isolation no
formal connection with other kids
is a dangerous spiral for a young child
how old is this is your your sister
she's 17. she's 17 how old are you
i am 28. 28 okay
um
yeah yikes
uh
have you had this conversation with your
mom before
no okay i've i've recently been on my
own healing journey from my childhood i
can imagine okay
um
so
you have to you have to you have to call
the child protective services
okay yeah this is what i was afraid of
you need to do it today
do it today yeah yeah today or let me
tell you this i'm gonna do it it's hard
because i know i'm gonna do it burn
bridges i know
listen the bridge has been burned
yeah and your sister's on that bridge
and it's on fire
okay you didn't light it
it's not by your hand but this fell into
your lap so now you got to deal with it
and this shouldn't be your job because
you're the child and it is
but someone's got to look after that
little girl
okay okay um i'll give you uh before i
call because now now what i have is a
report of a minor
who is struggling so before i
send in a uh report i'll give you 24
hours okay
okay here's what the follow-up looks
like okay
the follow-up it looks like this
you sit down and tell your mom
um well let me back out it sounds like
you're this your mom won't hear this
conversation it's not even a safe
conversation to have is that is that
true
it's it's like
yes that is true it's like i want her to
listen to this i i desperately want her
to but in the back of my mind i know
that she won't okay all right you're
right so
my approach all the time is to sit down
with somebody and have a hard
conversation with them
about what i'm gonna do
if they don't change fill in the blank
okay
i also one of my core tenants is only
speak if you can be heard
and this conversation i trust you would
be a waste of your time
and might even endanger your sister
further
oh okay okay
um
what i don't want is an adult in your
sister's life to come and say hey if
anybody asks you you better say this or
you're gonna be in big trouble you're
gonna get hurt again or whatever
hallucinations nightmares increasing
isolation this spinning out
my first thought
the question to ask you is is there a
chance she's been abused
um there's 100 percent chance she's
being
mentally and emotionally abused yeah
is there a chance she's been sexually
abused
not to my knowledge okay
um
okay
you need to make that call today
okay
and
yes it may blow things up yes it may
whatever it's the right thing to do
because your sister needs some some
significant um
interventions asap
okay
my hope is that the local school can
take care of that
there might be a chance that you end up
having to take her for a season
or an aunt that lives in that area takes
her first season and you get enrolled in
a public school and they'll work with
her um
but that isolation for what three four
years you said
um
yeah yeah probably
at least
when you say she's 100 being
psychologically and emotionally abused
what do you mean
i mean that it's coming from my mother i
have witnessed her um
gaslight her and um
completely ignore her
um request for help
like she's told her that she's in pain
or is she struggling with something and
my mom has told her
no you're not
you're making that up or you're
um
doing that to get attention or something
like that
yeah you gotta step in right now okay
okay okay
are you gonna make that call
um
gotta have gotta have to huh
yeah i would tell you besides the
ethical moral obligation and besides the
fact this is your little sister you have
a legal obligation you know of a child
that's in distress it's being neglected
and or abused then you gotta make that
phone call
okay okay how do i
how do i
i don't know how do i tell my mom that
i'm doing this
i don't know that you need to
oh okay
um
if if it was my
my parents wouldn't be in this situation
if it was an adult that could hear you
then you would sit down you'd either
have a phone call or you would go sit
down in person and say hey
i can no longer sit by while my sister
is struggling with these extreme
nightmares with the extreme isolation
with the
the
emotional and psychological abuse that's
going on in this home with a mom and dad
that completely ignore her needs she's
not doing well and i'm scared about the
outcome here and so
um either she goes into public school
effective tomorrow
we go enroll her tomorrow
so she can get the needs and services
that um
she is in desperate need of or i'm
calling cps
okay okay and when you call cps you tell
them i'm 28 years old my younger sister
has down syndrome she's 17
and um she's being psychologically and
emotionally abused she's having some
mental health breakdown issues and
they're being completely ignored
and so i'm calling to make a report of
child abuse
and i'm willing to take her into my home
while you'll investigate this
right okay
lay it out that cleanly facts are your
friends not does it need a long dark and
stormy night it just needs here's the
situation i'm reporting this call and
i'm willing to step up but i need you
all to go in and do your job
right okay
now if you think there's a chance you
call cps and they say great we're gonna
go look into it but it's gonna be about
three weeks or four weeks are she in
immediate danger do you know of any
physical abuse going on or whatever um
our backlog is x and y that may happen
um
it may be that you go sit with your mom
and say i would like sister to come live
with me for a while
right and just get her out of your home
would sister come live with you
oh yeah i would
it would be i would welcome her to come
live with me okay
that may be that may be your next step
um
i can feel my blood boiling here like it
oh man
uh man i don't talk about a lot on this
show but i spent the
bulk of my career working with kids with
young people and young adults and adults
with special needs
and
oh man
i i have a
rage inside of me
when people don't honor and love and
take care of kids special needs
also by the way parents listening
homeschooling is great
i'm a huge fan of it i love it
especially homeschooling done in a co-op
where you've got other people y'all are
connecting and they're learning from
different people i love it but
homeschooling just because you watch a
lot of internet stuff and you're like
these schools are teaching them this
stuff
and you do nothing
[Music]
golly you're hurting your kids when you
do that
kids have to have structure they have to
have boundaries they've got to have
intentional lessons intentional
um
pedagogy
and
golly dude love your kids enough
to turn the internet off and at least
send them to a public school at least
send them to a school that you can
afford at least send them to a
homeschool co-op where they can actually
get the education that they need if
you're not going to provide it for them
[Music]
i think we should go to break i'm gonna
get myself in trouble we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show thanks for being with us
sorry i threw a little timber tint from
there man
not taking care of kids special needs
makes me crazy
ah it gets me frustrated take care of
the people in your community and if
you're a brother or sister
and your siblings
are struggling they need help
um
it shouldn't be your job but it is step
up fill up fill in that gap help out
okay
and shout out to spinx from alabama the
meteorologist
today's song is a great one from
creighton's clear water revival
it's the question people my friends in
texas are asking have you ever seen the
rain
it goes like this
someone told me long ago there's a calm
before the storm i know it's been coming
for some time and when it's over so they
say it'll rain a sunny day i know
shining down like water
i want to know
have you ever seen the rain
coming down on a sunny day yesterday and
days before sun is cold and rain is hard
and i know
been that way for all my time until
forever on it goes through the circle
fast and slow i know it can't stop
i wonder
i want to know have you ever seen the
rain
coming down on a sunny day
i don't know all right
i have have you kelly
yeah a couple times once or twice
[Music]
we'll see you soon
[Music]